In linear regression, we are given data and data has still has more than one dimension.
We have just studied for two dimensions throughout this class.
So this might be the data and we're looking for the best line that fits the data.
We'll put differently the parameters a and b that we discussed before that defines the line.
The word best is interesting.
Obviously, it's impossible to put a line through the data points over here.
These are what's called nonlinear data that go up and down.
Data often looks like this even if the relationship between x and y is linear--
that's usually what's called noise in the data, some amount of randomness you can't explain.
So in finding the best fit, we're trying to find a line that minimizes the difference between the data
and the line in the y direction and that's somewhat counter intuitive.
You'd normally think the distance is given by these lines over here in red
and that is the shortest distance irrespective of x and y.
But in linear regression, it turns out that we're minimizing the distance just in the y direction.
And there's a lot of theory why this is a good idea.
In summary, we assume that our data is the result of this blank some unknown linear function,
bx+a+noise and if this noise is assumed to be Gaussian, they're minimizing the quadratic deviation
between the data points and the line happens to be the correct mathematical answer.
But leaving this aside, what we're doing is we are adding over all data points
the difference between our function and the y value of the data point with the square
and that distance is the distance we're minimizing.
So let's look into this with examples--for the following four data points,
which of these lines has the smallest quadratic error
and would be the best regression line--pick one of the three.